[Music]
we all have certain TV shows that we
want to watch right without being
interrupted or bothered absolutely well
luckily there's a new service that can
make sure your TV viewing experience is
not ruined take a look at their
commercial what's your watchin my
favorite show Game of Thrones what are
those guys doing getting revenge for
something that happens seven episodes
ago why are you yelling at me we've all
been there trying to enjoy a TV show
while having to explain four seasons of
backstory to a casual viewer well now
you can do something about it I got this
is the new revolutionary service that
will field all those annoying questions
so you can enjoy your show in peace
here's how it works are those dragons
were pets I got this that's Daenerys the
daughter of the mad king and those
dragons are actually her children our
counselors will happily answer all the
questions you can't believe you're being
asked questions like who's he who's she
what's that why is any of this happening
wait is this the girl from before which
of them is the bad guy is that Dermot
Mulroney and many more and if you
upgrade to premium membership you'll get
expert level service straight from the
source
that's Sansa Stark who was supposed to
marry King Joffrey
the kid saw his father at Ned Stark even
though he was the hand of the King to
his friend King Robert Baratheon thought
he was draw for his father but really
Joffrey's father is his uncle Jaime
Lannister who's in love with his twin
sister Queen Cersei Lannister who
accuses her other brother Tyrion
Lannister who was forced to marry Sansa
Stark of murdering his nephew King
Joffrey I got this can get that person
in your life up to speed on literally
thousands of titles so are you ready to
never answer another question again from
someone who has no idea what's going on
hey guys it's this commercial all about
[Applause]